so now queen of Christmas is a title we
have affectionately bestowed upon you
right and I know you've earned it but
what do you think of the title queen of
Christmas well I never called myself
queen of Christmas other people started
calling me queen of Christmas and I was
like oh that's so cute but I wasn't like
that's
me I don't know let's get it on a shirt
now I feel like we need to sell merch
yeah I mean it's it's fun you know what
I mean it's really and it's flattering
you know it's a testament to the
longevity of your Christmas music I mean
29 years right I don't know I haven't I
wasn't born when I first started that's
right I forgot time yes you're right
it's time now it's time now now it's
time we don't know what time it is we
don't know what time it is but it's
[Laughter]
time it's
time I
don't Christmas there
is the queen of Christmas has defrosted
what's exciting is uh you're about to
give Santa a run for money cuz you're
taking your Christmas Extravaganza on
the road uh Merry Christmas one and all
how would you describe this show well
until I get out there and start doing it
I'm not going to know but um it's not
that I'm not going to know I'm I'm
immersed in the music I'm just super
excited to be with the fans and you know
just have an experience with them um on
the road together for a Merry Christmas
one and all so um yeah getting going
it's getting into the frosty weather
soon and all of that you're bringing a
different kind of sleigh huh that's
right what's the one part of the show
that you're excited to bring to fans um
I think really it's it's kind of a
popery of sorts it's kind of like you
know we start with the sugar plump fairy
and go all the way through many holiday
hymns and the regular holiday songs and
then some of my songs that um I haven't
done in a while that I obviously I must
have been frozen when I did them but
they're um some big some my other big
hit songs so they're coming out the ice
block too they're coming out too and um
you know so so we we get the like I said
a popery of songs a whole the whole
Shang when you say that I also see
sights but smell it as well like there
sights and smells it's a 4D experience
if feel yes for sure how many different
ensembles are we working with for this
tour Mariah we're working with on the
outside like 10 okay but really I can't
do 10 costume changes so we have about
four that I'm very excited about and
then if I need to swap some out I was
going to ask yeah you might rotate if
you need to rotation never hurt anybody
no not at all especially when it's you
and especially when it's Christmas I
feel like it must be so fun to kind of
put those kind of looks together to
really complete the visual yeah it is
fun to put those kind of looks together
because it's a it's a holiday
themed concert but again it's also doing
my own records that are not holiday
themed so you kind of get to mix and
match with you know the Wardrobe and all
the things I love it well we love a
theme clearly you know it's a theme it's
a theme yeah it's festive it's F it's
time speaking of okay so that it's time
video I mean I checked at the time of
this interview it has 119 million views
in counting which apparently is the most
viewed video on X AKA Twitter I mean the
fans ate this one up how much fun was it
filming this one especially cuz your
kids got to be a part of it yeah it was
a lot of fun cuz we started putting this
video together like September wow
September maybe October 1st and um so it
was really it was really fun because we
had to do everything from scratch and
then put a lot of it in and post and
then just decide like what it was going
to be when we landed in in Christmas
time you know which is on um the top of
uh what is the what's the biggest
mountain again uh Mount Everest it was
on the top of Mount Everest there you go
I'm like about to say Mount Fuji and all
different I will said Rushmore so
don't but there was visual effects in
this one huh you had you said post yes
it was post come on budget come on I did
it myself good for you know and next
year but um no it was it was a lot of
fun and to get all those details
together was just like you know it took
a while but it was fun well Rock and row
um I know they've joined you on stage in
the past I hear they're going to be part
of this show as well in some capacity
yes they are okay I obviously see your
kids on Tik Tok as well I mean they are
so talented and they are hams like they
just love the camera
[Music]
yes are you proud of that I'm proud of
them in general they just know so many
things and and they're like on top of
everything and yes they're going to be
coming around the country with with me
and doing their thing and I'm excited to
to watch them they're growing fast it's
don't even remind know but now are is
mom giving them tips on their Tik toks
though like for example the perfect
lighting you know stuff like that well
they don't really care about it like I
care about it I care about but they know
that I care about it so you know I love
that they'll know if we're in a poorly
lit room they'll be like Mom this room
is not the lighting is so
bad rock and roll their Christmas wish
list is it wild or is it pretty
manageable uh last year it was wild okay
yeah cuz they're getting older you know
well everything is somehow technology
driven so it's not necessarily cheap um
not that I want it to be cheap but like
you know I like them to have a lot of
presents to open and everything else but
then they sort of don't care about the
other ones they live for the ones that
are you know a little more on the
expensive side I love it okay I want to
know what Bri carry is like during the
holidays off stage so like for example
be honest how long does your tree stay
up cuz like it'll be 2 weeks into the
New Year I'm still staring at that thing
in my living room oh my trees plural
stay up for a long long time yes okay I
mean when do they go away when I leave
for whatever what the next adventure is
going to be then they go away I see okay
it's all about that for me it's all yeah
yeah now I know you have a direct line
to Santa but what does someone like your
loved ones get Mariah carry for
Christmas like what's on your wish list
what's the ideal holiday gift I I
started telling people get me a gift
that just don't think that I could use
anything but it's the thought that
counts it's like get your friend or your
relative or whatever get them something
right you know just it doesn't have to
be amazing that's sentimental maybe but
also thoughtful to the person you're
purchasing it for yes okay I love it so
you wouldn't mind a handmade gift then
like something that was made at home no
I wouldn't mind okay as long as there's
like a little I'm waiting for the
diamonds of course me too honey okay me
too yes so let's keep that in mind
people friends there's a range but we
know what she wants yeah you know even
the smallest of diamonds can make a
lovely little Accent on any any gift
plenty of gift do you indulge during the
holidays like the rest of us like my
thing's tamali like what's yours you
like tamali I do I do I don't I don't
have much of a sweet tooth
I have this s that goes feeling so hot
to mol yes I love it um yeah what do you
indulge in over the holidays or do you
not my new thing is going to be
butterscotch pudding I haven't started
with it yet but I had it at a restaurant
the other night it was so good now
you're ready I was like yeah I was like
I have to get the recipe for that I love
it yeah now aside from the tour what are
your holiday plans and who are you
spending it with I'm spending it with my
kids and some friends and um we'll be an
aspen and we'll be on a two horse open
sleigh ride okay Santa's coming over as
well you think I'm lying no I believe
you I don't think you're lying at all
I'm telling you that's your that's your
homie right there that is my homie and
so he's going to be coming over and then
we're going to well before that we're
going to go on a two horse open sleigh
um which happens on the 23rd awesome and
yeah it's the best so Santa plays mhm
hot cocoa everything yes well we know of
course you love the Lambs and US Lambs
love you I'm asking this for the fans
will you be gifting the fans any new
music in the Horizon so I've been
working on some new music okay um I have
about 10 songs because we just kept me
and my writing partner just kept writing
and writing and um yeah it's it's been
fun because I've been like oh I guess
we're making a new album you know so you
don't really plant it it just kind of is
more organic happens yeah oh I love it
are you liking what you're putting down
I really am we worked yesterday in the
studio with some singers some choir and
doing one of those kind of songs so
that's some of the best parts of the
Christmas album is the choir stuff like
I mean the gospel singers on that is
just incredible so yeah we're working on
some stuff for that it's exciting what's
one word you would use to describe this
Christmas tour festive of course of
course it is what else could I do what
else could I
say